this is an Oreo and this is Bruno Oreos
have been around for more than 100 years
and Bruno he's been a food scientist for
20 years the first thing that comes to
mind to me is how convenient it is that
they have this flap then you can eat as
many as you want and as a food scientist
I usually always look at the label to
see what they add to that product So
today we're gonna break down the
ingredients inside the Oreo cookie
so the cream or the filling is a very
interesting quality development
challenge because it does not have any
dairy product in it so they spell cream
as c-r-e-m-e which is how we spell it in
Portuguese by the way in the way that
they achieve that texture the creaminess
it's by combining sugar with oils and
soy lecithin soy lecithin basically
works as an emulsifier replacing the
proteins from milk and eggs but Bruno
will show you how it works water and oil
do not mix and because the density of
oil is less in the density of water when
I combine them together we should be
able to see the oil floating up to the
surface that's where the soy lecithin
comes into play so the idea is we should
be able to add some lecithin to this
solution here and make the oil stay
longer in suspension in water in the
smaller the particles of oil that we can
make the better and you can see that one
thing that is already happening is that
lecithin also stabilizes the air in
suspension here that's why it's used to
make ice cream for example
there are three types of oil listed on
the package but Bruno says the most
important one might be palm oil the
reason why palm oil and coconut oil for
that matter are so important for the
food industry today is because it allows
us to substitute animal fats that are
solid at room temperature with a
vegetable fat the main reason why we are
somewhat resistant to using palm oil
nowadays is because of the Agricultural
practices around it increased demand for
palm oil has put rainforests at risk
Oreo's parent company says it's taking
steps to ensure it sustainably sources
its palm oil with the company accounting
for about 0.5 percent of palm oil
consumption
now for the sweetness that makes an Oreo
well an Oreo if you use high
concentration of sugar and you don't use
a very refined type of sugar there will
be some uh noticeable texture like
graininess in the product there are
several types of sweeteners listed on
the Oreo packages The Wall Street
Journal purchased one of those types
high fructose corn syrup one of these
ingredients that revolutionized the
industry there's a lot of enzymatic
processes so we modify the starch from
corn we break it down with an enzyme
called amylase amylase will convert the
starch into glucose but then we use
another enzyme that modifies the glucose
and converts that into fructose and
fructose is much more sweet than glucose
one of the Oreo packages The Wall Street
Journal bot listed invert sugar on its
ingredients the FDA recognizes both
ingredients as safe but recommends the
consumers limit consumption of all added
sugars Oreo's parent company agrees
there are some concerns about the fact
that as animals we are not used to be
exposed to that amount of sweetness and
we may eat too much of the food just
because it's sweeter tastes so awesome
another aspect contributing to the
cream's taste flavoring
one package of Oreos listed natural
flavor while the other listed artificial
flavoring which is a broad term required
by the FDA when a flavoring agent isn't
coming from one of these natural sources
on its website Oreo specifically
mentions vanillin commonly used to
create the flavor of vanilla
now for the cookie
Oreo declined a comment on which
ingredients go in the cookie and which
go in the filling because some of the
ingredients can be used in either or
both it's a little difficult to break
down the ingredients per part of the
cookie but you can certainly say for
example that wheat is certainly used for
the the cookie or the wafer we know that
wheat is the most significant component
of this product because it is listed
first in the ingredients list the order
of the ingredients is such that it
reflects the proportion of the
ingredients in the product in this case
is enriched with several vitamins these
ingredients for example is added folic
acid which is a vitamin that is
important to help prevent more formation
of babies you can buy enriched flour in
in any grocery store that's widely
available and they usually have exactly
the same vitamins leavening agents also
help the dough rise baking soda and or
calcium phosphate all these salts will
release CO2 you release a gas when they
are heated in the product and that's
what creates that fluffiness that as the
product bakes and solidifies it becomes
a crumbly and and soft to the bite as
for the chocolate so we have chocolate
mentioned later and we also have cocoa
processed with Alkali that means it was
treated with an alkaline solution
typically made with potassium carbonate
or sodium bicarbonate and that's a
common modification that is made with in
cocoa beans to make them taste more
neutral so less acidic and also darkens
the product a little bit so it looks
like we covered all the ingredients here
oh and there is salt probably just a
small amount of it because of course it
is supposed to be sweet and this reminds
me of my grandma she always said that
you always put a little bit of salt in
sweet foods and a little bit of sugar in
Savory food so shout out to Grandma so
these products is made stable by
basically not having much water in it at
all by not having water you prevent
microbial growth in spoilage there are a
few things to note on the packaging
says that this product is made with
bioengineered ingredients bioengineering
may sound scary but it's simply the
replacement of genes or pieces of the
chromosome of the plant with others of
interest for example you can copy the
gene in one plant that is resistant to a
pest and put that into the soybeans and
then you grow the soybeans and that
plant might become resistant to that
past before those products are used
commercially and and distributed as food
in the United States they have to be
approved by several agencies and
approved by the FDA as generally
recognized as safe or grass Oreo didn't
comment on which specific ingredients
are genetically modified its parent
company says the scientific consensus on
the safety of genetically modified food
ingredients is clear
and Bruno see some opportunities for
improvements the only question that I
would have is why they still use soy
lecithin soy is an allergen so whenever
possible we want to replace a neurogenic
ingredient with one that is not
allergenic there's only a few food
products that have lasted for more than
a century and Oreo is one of them so
whenever you are that food scientist
making the decisions on what to change
in the formulation you better know your
stuff
get this upside down
there's no way you can
pretty interesting
[Music]